so again this year has been fantastic
for you did you ever think that you
would be breaking through in the genre
of country music never it's so
unexpected but I think the best things
in life are so I will gladly take that
yeah now you know this collaboration has
borrow like fantastic for you for you
know what's what are the opportunities
that have come out of this our people
just knocking down your door to want to
work with you and have you write songs
for them yeah it's been it's been
incredible especially like being at the
CMAs or being at you know being in the
country community I think it's taught me
a lot about songwriting and how to write
real honest records and meeting other
people but also I had something like
text me recently and saying like hey you
know this song that I wrote that's out
right now it was inspired by meant to be
in that that really was cool to me you
know so is there a difference when
you're working in that community the
music community in terms of how people
work and also how their fans react to
you totally I think that there's love
all the time but in the country
community it's completely different it's
a more traditional conservative world
and it's like a family vibe when you do
the award shows in the country community
all the females share one dressing room
like you had Carrie Underwood and Maren
Morris and Reba and like in just one
dressing room it was in like pop
festivals we all have to have our own
dressing room and who has the biggest
dressing room and I love them who do you
want to collab with next I don't know
I love Kanye West I love Alanis
Morisette I love Lauryn Hill
I just want to collaborate with somebody
from that inspired me from my past I was
more that clever yeah I love I love her
because she's super strong and she
taught me a lot of bad words and her
songs about how it's a song rate and not
be scared to say everything that's on
your minds is there anyone who you look
at that you know that might be popular
but you don't buy their message that you
don't think they would be a good fit for
you probably some of the rappers out
today I feel like I mean a lot of young
kids love the rappers and like when I
grew up they said that in the past you
know they spoke about selling drugs
which is not any better but now it's all
about taking the drugs and only
so I think that it's really important I
mean we all go through all things and I
think it's part of our stories and if
it's true to them that's cool
I just feel like I wouldn't I wouldn't I
don't want to work with somebody who I
would never do a song it's like I don't
know about promoting that kind of yeah
like I don't mind if it's like part of
your story yeah like with Monster and
Eminem like he did that it was really
cool because he's talking about his
challenges of being you know stuck not
like you know being stuck on some drugs
and stuff like that and I respected that
because he's telling his truth but it's
like if it's like you're telling telling
people to like constantly take it out I
don't mess with that well I'm a mess
isn't filling your truth yeah right you
know you talk a lot about your inner
voice and your inner voice yeah
tells you so how do you shut that off
how do you shut that down when your
inner voice is being negative was being
you yeah I think that you just accept it
and you go like okay this is like
happening right now and I I think when
you try to stop it completely it like
get slapped the voice gets louder so you
have to accept you know your
insecurities and things that you're
afraid of but then also tell yourself
the positive like because you got I
think our minds can are get easily
trained to be negative sometimes and you
have to like say like if you keep saying
like mean things about yourself like I
used to do that all the time it just
makes you feel worse and those words
become real in a sentence right and if
you say nice things yourself I feel like
it becomes better
it's like mine of it matter right yeah
sorry if I'm like mumbling a little bit
you know how long day I'm sure you've
had a lot of interviews too well what's
your inner voice telling you now that
you're here you performed it's a big
party um my inner voice is telling me to
go get some food okay now it's it's been
amazing here in Toronto and it's I think
it's been my favorite trip yet no not
only because tonight but I've been able
to really like see the city and go to
the water and take a boat ride and try
the food and it's just been such a like
an awesome experience and I feel like I
finally seen her on to it in a really
cool light and I want to come back so
yeah and then plus winning an award and
going to MMVAs is awesome too but it's
been really fun so I want to go out and
even my mom and my team because
proud of what we did tonight nicely
should be has awesome thanks a lot thank
you